companies can ban employees from wearing
visible religious symbols at work
including Muslim head staffs fallen the
ruling from the European Court of
Justice the decision states of
prohibiting political philosophical or
religious signs at work is not
discriminatory if it's applied to all
members of staff equally when element
and Anna Gilbert is a senior associate
in employment law wentworth shouid so no
amnesty is said this is going to lead to
a rise in religious discrimination among
employees is that right I don't think it
will I can see why the decision on the
face of it may seem controversial but
ultimately employers in the UK would be
very vulnerable to discrimination claims
if they started banning the headscarf
sit at work unless they can objectively
justify that ban and that's quite hard
to do but in theory though turbans
Jewish kippers crucifixes could all now
be barred by employers if they so wish
no the decision doesn't have that kind
of impact on law in the UK at all the
decision in the ECJ related mainly to
what's called direct discrimination
whereas the main type of the main risk
of claim would be an indirect
discrimination claim which is where an
employer applies a policy equally to
everybody in order to do that and if
that adversely affects a certain
religious faith for example they would
need to object to justify that the bar
is quite high for that so it's not as
simple as it seems so what if what was
an employer have to do then if they
wanted to start imposing these sort of
measures they'd have to have a good
reason for the ban that normally
tribunals would want to see some sort of
Health and Safety or since a real
practical reason and not not just for
example the the company's identity or
brand and it wouldn't it wouldn't bow to
pressure from customers for example if
they didn't want to see an employee
wearing a headscarf at work British
Airways fell foul of this a few years
ago when they told one of their
employees not to wear a crucifix at work
and they got into all sorts of trouble
over that I mean presumably under this
ruling would be a be within their rights
to demand that again no I think it would
change the decision that was made in the
BA case and ultimately she was actually
successful in the end because they did
change their policy which allowed that
kind of religious dress or religious sin
to be worn on a necklace and that showed
that their policy wasn't actually
necessary but I mean could people
potentially lose their job if they
didn't fall in with what employers
demand in terms of dress codes from now
on that they could but whether it's fair
or lawful as another question and it you
know employers would still have to
ensure that any policy can be objected
to justified and it have to be necessary
and fair and reasonable in all the
circumstances and that the bar is quite
high for that and normally focuses on
health and safety and practical issues
such as working with heavy machinery or
working in a children's nursery for
example
what's it and what's it what's the
employers attitude in general here in
the UK to things like this do you see it
much in your in your work well in my
experience dress codes while it's
important that they are applied
consistently across the board I do think
employers are quite mindful that they
need to be flexible when it comes to
people with certain religious faiths and
their requirement to wear headscarves
and we don't see many of these cases in
our line of work luckily some some
religions are more equal than others all
religions should be treated equally and
the law does provide for that